[Music]
don't take a knee don't sit down don't
play in American for them to not come
out that Soldier Field it's dedicated
for the military and for them to be that
disrespectful and not come out on
soldiers field I'm done with it there's
other ways that you can give a stance
and you give a say and I don't think it
should be through our National Anthem
I think it's shameful and I would like
to see those Colts players leave the
country and leave the team welcome back
to Hannity our new time live 9:00
Eastern now those were some NFL fans who
are not happy with the players who
disrespected our national anthem and our
flag earlier tonight the vice president
Mike Pence he spoke out on this very
issue let's take a look I stand with
President Donald Trump
and I will always stand for our National
Anthem we've all got a right to our
opinions but I don't think it's too much
to ask the players in the National
Football League to stand for our
National Anthem it's about respect for
the flag respect for the country and
most importantly it's about respect for
all those who fought and died to defend
it here not with reaction former Trump
White House chief strategist his first
cable interview since leaving the White
House the executive chairman of
Breitbart news Steve added mr. bannon
you're like you did one interview that
I've seen you my entire life of you
although you've been on the program
before good to see you and you're
joining us from Alabama tonight we'll
get to football in a minute tell us why
you are in Alabama Mike Pence was that
one rally you were at another for Roy
Moore tell us why I'm here - I'm here to
support president Donald J Trump what
I'm here to do is to support Donald J
Trump by having folks down here support
judge Roy Moore I think Roy Moore is the
guy that's going to represent Donald
Trump and fight the establishment I mean
it's very simple this election is 30
million dollars being spent by Mitch
McConnell and that crew of corrupt and
incompetent politicians and consultants
they've raised thirty million dollars of
outside money to destroy judge Moore
judge Moore's raise about two million so
Shawn it's very clear to me that's where
I got Laura Ingraham and in Levin and
dr. Savage and and you know Mark Meadows
everybody any support that have been
hardcore Trump supporters and Sean
Hannity hardcore some Trump supporters
that have that have thrown down with
with judge Moore so I'm very proud to be
down here this is the first time I've
really done ever done a campaign event I
get my the old bomber jacket on do the
complete rig I used to wear during
during during the campaign with with
President Trump and I said tonight
Whitney of Sarah Palin louis gomer all
of us the hardcore Trump people we're
not here to defy President Trump we were
here to praise and honor him and we
think the best way to do that is to send
somebody to Washington DC out of Alabama
the good folks at Alabama to send
somebody that's going to have Donald
Trump saying I totally I believe
more is going to be more the outsider
and the fact that Mitch McConnell and
the establishment of pouring millions of
dollars into this race into that state
tells me that Luther Strange is going to
end up being in some ways in you know
having to support them and more inclined
to support them and frankly I think the
biggest disappointment in DC you
actually said it in an interview I think
to a certain extent Mitch McConnell and
does not support the president's agenda
economic agenda and it's obvious he
hasn't gotten a thing done Steve in
eight months we're now in the ninth
month of the Trump presidency there's no
excuse for that in my opinion it's first
its its first it's very simple you know
strange can't sit there and say I'm
going to stand up to Mitch McConnell I'm
going to Washington stand up to Mitch
McConnell's gave me thirty million
dollars thirty million dollars not to
come down here to Alabama and debate the
issues they're not in debating illegal
immigration or the trade deals or
anything like that that what they're
what this was about was the politics of
personal destruction the exact same game
plan that they ran on Donald Trump this
is not debated that this is not about
doing the this is not about doing
everything about a debate this is about
trying to destroy Roy Moore just like
they tried to destroy Donald J Trump you
know in in many ways I think the
destroyed Trump media will misinterpret
the list of people that you mentioned
including myself I want Roy Moore to win
this race tomorrow and they'll try and
create a divide it's actually to support
the president and I understand the
president's a loyal guy had a
relationship with ruthless strange I
endorsed mo Brooks in the first run
around here I've known him 27 years I
know he's a good man but I do believe
what you're saying here and the explain
the ads that are being run because they
look like they could have been written
and produced by Nancy Pelosi and Chuck
Schumer they're worse I mean this is
what karl rove and steven law and ward
baker this is what they've done they try
to give ammunition to the democrats
later on if judge more wins tomorrow I
mean this is unacceptable they've done
the cruelest nastiest ads I've ever seen
to destroy judge more
a righteous man and his wife and his
family this is the same thing they did
with Donald Trump this is not about
debating the issues they tried to
destroy Donald Trump the same the same
gang that's going after Roy Moore is the
same gang that went after Donald Trump
and I gotta tell ya I think it's some
time later after tomorrow a real you
know review has to be done of how
President Trump got the wrong
information and came down on the wrong
side of the football here because I
agree with you I love mo Brooks and I
was really shocked to see mobile works
not getting to the second round
you know Brooks is a good man mo Brooks
has stood with us he stood with Jeff
Sessions for for many many years and
he's a good man this should have never
happened
this should have never had Hannity and
Palin and Levin and dr. Savage and Laura
Ingraham all the people that are diehard
Trump people all the people are there
for the beginning we're not sunshine
Patriots we're Fort Worth Donald Trump
through thick and thin this should clear
on and this has got to be reviewed this
is not a referendum on the president the
way the media wants to do I would argue
this is a referendum on McConnell do you
agree with that analysis this is a
referendum on the party at Davos and the
elites in Davos and in the United States
in Washington DC that Mitch McConnell is
the face of absolutely that's what the
referendum it's very simple tomorrow the
good folks at Alabama gonna decide if
sovereignty rests with the people or it
is a rest with the money is it going to
be the muscle of the grassroots versus
the money of a corrupt and incompetent
permanent political class that rules
Washington DC like a new aristocracy you
know we've had similar attacks over the
course of our careers I know they called
you Darth Vader I did like your line
when you're on 60 minutes when you said
I'm a street fighter because that's kind
of how I view things I fight for the
things that I believe in and the people
in this country that have been left
behind
I don't know who'd win in a fight but we
fight for principle and things that are
important and helping men and women that
are suffering but I resent the tactics
when they used Republican on Republican
whatever happened in Reagan's 11th
commandment every two and four years the
Democrats say Republicans a racist
sexist misogynist xenophobic homophobic
Islamophobic those ads I saw down in
Alabama against Roy Moore Aiken
serve ative will run by Republican Steve
what's happening here the Republican
they're the elites represented by Mitch
McConnell right hold me in contempt
right they think I'm a bad guy they
think I'm a dangerous guy
I wear their contempt as a badge of
honor okay they're they have they have
helped destroy this country they have
done nothing but allow economic hate
crimes against the working men and women
in the heartland of this country the
factories went to China and the drugs
came in okay we've got to stop it
tomorrow in Alabama the good folks
Alabama gotta got a choice this is Jeff
Sessions seat Sean you know how close I
am to Jeff Sessions I know how close you
are to Jeff Sessions Jeff Sessions has
been our mentor Jeff Sessions is a man
with a pure heart and toughest boot
leather this seat is Jeff session seat
and that's why tomorrow I hope the folks
in Alabama send another righteous man a
righteous man like Jeff Sessions I hope
they send judge Moore
I hope they send judge Moore into the
into the runoff with the Democrat one
comment you made since you left the
White House I didn't like and when you
said to the extent that the Trump
presidency that a lot of us fought for
which i think is the Forgotten men and
women agenda of this country and they
deserve to be served
especially after eight years of Obama 13
million more Americans on food stamps
eight million more in poverty lowest
labor participation rate these are real
people real lives real damage I didn't
like when you said the Trump presidency
we fought and voted for and you thought
was over because you're still fighting
for it I'm still fighting for it and
people in this country are fighting for
it every day and I don't think it's over
yet I think this is only beginning in a
lot of ways it's not going to be over if
we fight and help President Trump
President Trump needs helps the reason I
left the White House I told him I was
gonna go after the establishment Garf
the establishment first and the
Democrats that look it's Mitch McConnell
and Paul Ryan have allowed three there's
three investigative committees on
Capitol Hill they have full subpoena
power they have unlimited president
Trump yeah going after him every day let
me ask you let's watch him every day I
never heard of the term all right until
this election never now this all laugh
radical left
so I don't even know what that means
what does it mean to you and secondly
because they try to imply it's racist I
wanted to get your comments about the
president I think speaking out rightly
for the flag and for the anthem and for
the men and women who served this
country you know about taking the need
for the national anthem I said in this
speech tonight
if people in this country taken me and
the National Football League players
want to take a knee they should take a
knee at night every night and thank God
in heaven Donald J Trump as president
knighted States he has saved this
country so much grief he has done such a
tremendous job with virtually no help
and that's where I meant when I said
that I stepped out to make sure that
Mitch McConnell in the Republican
establishment starts to have a
Republican back because you know what
Mitch McConnell wouldn't be Majority
Leader if Donald Trump didn't drag a
half a dozen senators across the
goal-line in November so it's time for
the Republican establishment to step up
and have the back of President Trump all
right Steve ban hope you come on the
program more often appreciate you being
with us thank you so much on our first
9:00 p.m. show as we move back a new
timeslot which was our old timeslot
all right